in my second company Prestige Labs I
built up to over 5,000 Affiliates that
generated 20 plus million dollar a year
in revenue and that business continues
to this day in Allen my software company
which was my third big company we built
up to over a thousand Affiliates that
were agencies white labeling that
software for my book launch for $100
million leads we got 30,000 Affiliates
who promoted the actual book launch I've
also invested in companies that I've
personally endorsed and so I bring all
these things up because most people
don't know how to quote monetize an
audience and after talking to a lot of
creators or celebrities and influencers
and also business owners who want to do
deals with those people a lot of people
don't share a construct in terms of
thinking through how to make those deals
happen and so I wanted to make this
video to outline the four ways that I
see those deals happening and the
combinations between them and what
considerations you might have whether
you're on the doing the deal side of
having an audience or being the person
who wants to quote buy license rent the
audience from an influencer or somebody
who has those eyeballs all right so four
ways to monetize an audience let's use a
good marker that doesn't
suck step one have good markers four
ways
to
monetize and
audience all right now right off the bat
number one we've got Affiliates which is
what I was saying
earlier the second way that you can
monetize an audience is through
sponsorships some people call these
endorsements the third way that you can
do this is through
Partnerships which usually involve
equity and the fourth way that we can do
this through starting your own if you're
the influencer in this instument
all right so we have Affiliates which is
where
you are getting paid after you make
sales for a business sponsorships where
they pay you first to advertise on
behalf of the business and typically
endorse it via your brand Partnerships
where you go into a business that
already has a product already has an
infrastructure and you do one of these
two things or a combination of these two
things for equity and so the behavior
avors between affiliate sponsorships and
Partnerships are more or less the same
the difference is simply how you get
compensated and then the fourth is where
you just start your entirely owned brand
to then promote to your audience all
right so let's break down which of these
and kind of where they sit on the
Continuum and the reason I want to bring
this up is because I'm having so many
conversations with people who are like I
have this audience I've built it for
four years I just don't know what to do
and so I think of these four on a
Continuum all right and I can think of
this Continuum in terms of difficult ult
and risk and value all right and so on
this side you've got the Affiliates this
is the fastest way that you could
immediately make money most businesses
that have affiliate programs you can
sign up automatically they have
predetermined uh terms that are
associated with this agreement and as
unless you do something that's really
you know nefarious or weird they're
happy to have you sell their stuff so
one is this one's fastest this is
lowrisk for kind of both
parties because if you are an affiliate
and you're promoting it like they don't
have to pay you until after you make a
sale now for you you also don't get
capped and so if you can make a ton of
sales and you feel like you're being
undervalued then you just get to prove
that you are actually good at promoting
and that your audience is actually a
good fit for whatever that product is
but from a value perspective so I call
it exit
value affiliate revenue streams are not
typically that valuable so they will
contribute to the sellability of the
company but the majority of that value
would come in the terms of a multiple of
the cash flow that you're receiving as
an affiliate multiplied or discounted by
how reliable the business that you're
doing business with is and so if I'm an
affiliate of the US government you know
what I mean and I recruit people for the
military then I probably can say that my
business model is sound and the US
government is not going to go away I'm
not getting not notwithstanding you know
theories and whatnot all right but by
and large it's be a trustworthy third
party on the flip side if I have some
you know info thing that is going to
disappear tomorrow because there's some
Arbitrage opportunity that your business
opportunity then this is going to be
basically have no value because that
business that underlines that cash flow
has no value all right and so we're
moving along here so this is the lowest
value probably middle work lowish risk
for you all right the next is you've got
sponsorships
so sponsorships is where someone pays
you first all right so you receive cash
and then you make the endorsement and so
usually this is in two forms you
advertise to your
audience and the reason I say advertise
rather than here it sell here you only
get paid after people buy with
sponsorships you get paid first and so
that means that you are advertising
you're a traffic source for the business
and so you will get paid as a traffic
Source typically based on cpms meaning
cost per Impressions that you can have
in terms of views to an audience now
these sponsorships come in the form of
you posting stuff to your audience which
for them they see this as free traffic
they're technically paying for it but
you're monetizing the traffic that you
have the other way which is the more
scalable way is something called
whitelisting which is basically them
taking whatever your posts are and then
running them as ads and so let's say I
have a million person audience I make a
post and only you know 200,000 people
see it and as most content creators
would do you wouldn't want to post over
and over again about that thing because
it would kind of be like oh this guy's
just promoting this thing over and over
again it wouldn't feel good right and so
you might make a post or two every so
often to not interrupt the value that
you're providing to your audience too
much and so the way to solve this really
for both parties is you make an
advertisement saying hey I just
partnered with so and so their thing is
awesome I've actually been using it for
years finally came to an agreement I
think you guys might like it check it
out right and so that wh listing then
allows them to blast it to people way
outside of your audience I like this a
lot as a win-win because the business
pays money to advertise your brand so
they make you bigger and they're
spending money to advertise you but at
the same time they get higher conversion
rate because you're probably better on
camera you're better spoken and you
already have a certain amount of warm
audience that recognize you at least
your face or your mannerisms so you
convert it a higher percentage so the
business makes money you grow your brand
this is a really nice partnership now
these deals sponsorships are harder to
come by than affiliate deals because
most affiliate companies just have a
program an influencer program an
affiliate program and you just sign up
on the standard terms sponsorships tend
to be more allak cart depending on the
size of the influencer relative to the
size of the company and so for extreme
examples if you're a huge influencer and
there's a tiny company you'll be able to
get an amazing sponsorship deal if it's
a huge company like Nike and you're a
small influencer you might not get any
deal and you still wear their stuff and
so it's really the balance between who
has how much leverage in the
negotiation which brings us to the
fourth one or sorry the third one which
is Partnerships all right now as we move
along
here
sponsorships also don't have kind of
like Affiliates huge exit value the only
place that sponsorships really become
exit valuable exit value for a business
is if you have a True Media company now
if you're a personal brand it's really
tough to exit your personal brand
but if I have an army of influencers and
I negotiate deals through my network and
say hey uh you know paps Blue Ribbon or
you know Budweiser whatever I have a
thousand influencers that fit your ideal
profile for customers and I'll negotiate
an umbrella deal and then all of them
are forced because the have with them to
promote your stuff now you have a media
company which is very similar to a
talent agency slightly different but has
a lot of similarities and so then then
that sponsorship revenue is really the
main revenue of your business which is
that you sell traffic at a discount
right but for the for the influencer
individually these two things very hard
to sell not really sellable not much now
once we get into this side these deals
get harder and harder to do and you do
fewer and fewer of them as you go down
this line so a partnership can either be
a minority deal or a majority deal again
if you're going to go partner with a
company and you're huge and they're tiny
then it might be a a majority deal if
they're huge and your tiny relative to
them then it might be a minority deal
meaning you're not going to get all of
the company and that can range from you
know
0.1% of the business all the way to you
getting you know 99% of the business in
terms of the range and so anything that
you can imagine in terms of economics
here is going to be negotiable but one
of the thing or some of the things that
I would consider here is performance
which is this is again for both
parties you can have Equity as the form
of compensation rather than necessarily
cash and you say hey if I bring you an
extra thousand customers I get you know
1% per th000 customers that I bring you
to the platform or whatever and then you
put a cap on that at some point where
you say up to to you know 10% great and
so that way it's a little bit balanced
for you and for the business now one of
the considerations that you have to have
if you were the uh content creator or
the influencer is that the the the
Association that you make with their
brand is permanent as soon as you make
that public decoration you transfer all
of that Goodwill you transfer that
Association to them and so if you are
going to do a deal like this my
recommendation is that you want to have
at least something
upfront so no matter what for doing this
deal you get some amount of this Equity
up front and then some percentage that's
based on performance now the one of the
last components that I'll say and
there's obviously a lot of ways that you
can do deals but these are just the
things that I think through is time
and so somebody who's on the business
owner side is like well I don't want you
to just make one Association I want you
to keep doing this for a long period of
time and so they can take some of this
Equity that they want to give you and
say all right I'm going to give you you
know 25% of your Equity upfront I'm
going to give you uh 25% based on
performance and I'm going to give you
50% over time and so I want you to
promote for the next four years and if
for some reason something happens then
you're not going to get that vesting
because we had some sort of breakup
right and so whenever I think through
these terms I just like to think through
all the W's which is who what where when
why how right which is okay I want you
to post and if you're the content grator
you should be asking that same thing
which is how much do you want me to post
right and about what and you have to
take into consideration that you have to
keep building your brand right and so
you don't want to just be like all of a
sudden some shill like that's not good
you want to Tastefully be able to
integrate that promotion into the
content that you have and so You' have
to say okay well I think the best way
for us to do this is for me to you know
put uh your links in my my bio and I'll
put it up for one week of the month and
I will make one long form thing that
mentions it and you know five short form
things via posts or stories and then
when you define that and the reason this
is so important is that you define that
stuff up front so that it's just very
clear don't just say like I will promote
the business and whatnot because it just
doesn't work as well and you might say I
will also you know record ads once a
month that you can then use for wh
listing and so all of these things and
this is where this gets more nuanced in
Deal making is is you can be a partner
and still have affiliate Revenue you can
be a partner and still get paid from a
sponsorship perspective and so these
things are not mutually exclusive but
like you might have a primarily
sponsorship deal with some element of
equity but I will say on a personal
level the more money you have right now
the more you want to lean this way
because the
equity the sponsorship cash that you
choose to take you do at the expensive
equity and if you believe in the product
and you believe that the company is exit
in the future then in my opinion it
makes sense to delay it for the little
bit longer run but this takes on more
risk because here you get paid today no
matter what here you might not ever get
paid if the company doesn't sell and so
by taking on more risk you want to make
sure that you're getting a
disproportionate reward in the in the
form of stock shares options equity and
things like that all right and so as
we're walking through this and you're
thinking okay how can I monetize my
brand it's like okay the first level I
can do Affiliates and just promote other
people's stuff and get paid for it the
next level I can be a media source for
them I can be traffic for them via
sponsor ship right these are a little
bit more nuanced deals taking another
step I can actually partner with the
brand and say Hey I want to own 1% 5%
10% 50% depending on how big you are and
how big your audience is and then
finally you can start your
own
brand and when I say brand I say that
all inclusive in terms of products and
brand and when you do this you can
either white label which which means you
go to somebody who manufactures stuff
already and say can you slap my logo on
it which is an option and the other
option is that you do custom
formulations custom I'll just say custom
stuff all right and so if I were selling
supplements for example I might go to a
a company that already has a product
that's done and I just say hey I want to
slap my label on it on the custom
version of this it's like hey I want
this gram of this we're going to test
out flavors together and we're going to
put it together make a custom product
that no one else has same things works
with merchandise so if you said hey I
want to get a white T-shirt and you just
try six different white t-shirts that
people have off the shelf that are
manufacturers they say okay just slap my
logo on it let's go or you say hey what
are the different Fabrics what are the
different materials that I can put
together these are the cuts that I want
to look at this is how I want it to fit
right that becomes more custom and so
white label is faster and easier from a
speed perspective but usually me
personally I prefer to do custom stuff
because I don't like anyone else being
able to sell something that's identical
to me and be able to have any kind of
pricing power over what I have because
the moment that people find out that you
just have a generic product that you
slap the label on it just does it's not
a good look right and so again I don't
think there's anything like I want to be
clear I don't think there's anything
wrong with doing white label I just
think that if we were to put this on
this sphere like white label would be
here and custom would be here but if
you're going to take the risk on of
starting your own brand I might as well
get all the benefits of doing it but
this costs more money white label tends
to Cost Less because you don't have to
get custom templates custom forms and
pay and incur all those costs costs
because someone else their whole
business is based around doing this for
other people all right now the
difference here is that for all of these
situations you're going to promote stuff
that already exists here you're starting
the thing from Ground Zero which means
that you're on the other side of the
table now you start with 100% equity and
then you start paying people this way
down the line and so if you are an
influencer you have an audience or
you're a business owner and you're
trying to make deals with influencers
this is how I think through this and I
try and see there are elements that you
can borrow from each of these kind of
verticals to tweak the deal to make it
right for everyone and so I think about
it in terms of what's the exit value
what cash is going to be going in or out
of the business how much work is the
person going to do and then how much
risk am I or are they exposed to and by
balancing those four things you can
usually navigate along this Continuum to
find the right part the right deal
that's right for you and the
product that's it